le féminisme de droite va laisser
s'épanouir la différence dans le privé
et prôner l'égalité dans le public là où
le féminisme de gauche tend justement à
vouloir imposer l'égalité dans le privé
et la différence dans le public
[Musique]
alors je dirais que le féminisme en tant
que isme effectivement est né à gauche
notamment dans cette pensée la
déconstruction inauguré par simone de
beauvoir dans le deuxième sexe ou quand
elle vit on ne naît pas femme on le
devient que la différence des sexes
finalement n'est qu'une construction
sociale est aujourd'hui ce féminisme là
il a été radicalisé notamment par la
théorie du genre et aujourd'hui on n'a
même pas un féminisme de gauche mais un
féminisme plutôt d'extrême-gauche le
féminisme radical qui entreprend de
déconstruire radicalement la différence
des sexes et de promouvoir une forme de
neutralité absolue et qui est très très
idéologique et qui promeut une forme de
guerre des sexes
y a pas à proprement parler de féminisme
de droite mais il ya des femmes de
droite qui se sont battus pour leurs
droits des femmes conservatrice
d'ailleurs on pourrait dire
paradoxalement que sous l'ancien régime
au xviiie siècle dans les salons les
femmes avaient beaucoup plus de pouvoir
que l'on auquel en nombre ont par la
suite après la révolution française
c'est elisabeth vigée-lebrun la pomme ce
peintre de marie antoinette qui disait
les femmes rennais alors la révolution
les a détrôné et d'ailleurs il ya eu
tout le long du deuxième siècle une
grande méfiance de la part des
révolutionnaires des républicains des
hommes de gauche envers les femmes les
femmes qui étaient jugées trop
conservatrices trop proche de l'église à
qui il ne fallait surtout pas donner le
droit de vote parce qu'elle allait faire
élire justement les réactionnaires et
donc finalement qui a donné le droit de
vote en france aux femmes c'est le
général de gaulle un homme de droite et
la droite a accordé de nombreux droits
aux femmes sous le général de gaulle
évidemment mais aussi sous giscard et
même parfois elle attend t elle à elle a
eu tendance à être à la remorque
idéologique de la gauche en allant très
très loin par exemple sur la parité
puisque la loi copé zimmermann de 2010
instaurer la parité dans les conseils
d'administration est une loi votée par
la droite qu'on voit que la gauche n'a
pas le monopole loi protégeant les
femmes
je pense que là où le féminisme de
gauche tend à promouvoir un objet qu'ils
prétendent et construire en même temps
en disant finalement il faut des femmes
partout mais la femme n'existe pas le
féminisme le droit de sera plus incarné
il va prendre en compte l'existence
d'une différence des sexes pour répondre
tout simplement aux problèmes concrets
qui se posent aux femmes notamment la
conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale la
maternité les questions de reproduction
finalement le féminisme droite va
chercher plutôt à construire des crèches
plutôt que de décrire en écriture
inclusive pour être un peu caricatural
féminisme de droite va laisser
s'épanouir la différence dans le privé
et prôner l'égalité dans le public là où
le féminisme de gauche tend justement à
vouloir imposer l'égalité dans le privé
et la différence dans le public à
travers une obsession de la parité je
pense que finalement le féminisme de
droite doit être un féminisme
réconciliateur qui ne cherchent pas à
opposer les sexes mais plutôt à les
concilier et même à les rendre
complémentaires